from where you are from
you could let us know in the chat where
your
at least
eight country is
very interested to hearing
and as you can see we'll be getting
started in about a couple minutes
Ellie
Maybe
Tamil Nadu
Andhra Pradesh
another person from Delhi
Bangalore
arashtra
so you can see we have Professor Sandeep
Shukla here with us he'll be uh taking
us
to the session uh conversation with me
another person from Bangalore
so welcome to everybody
glad to see you here this evening
adisha
so I hope everybody is eager to hear
what uh
Professor Shukla has to say
okay
very good
all right and welcome everyone uh we are
going to be talking about blockchain and
blockchain careers
uh in today's session as I mentioned we
have Professor Sandeep Shukla here
[Music]
and uh
just before we get started a couple of
Basic Ground on the set
there we go
we'd like you to put your questions in
the Q a box in
um
Zoom that will help us keep track of
them separately from the chat stream
uh it makes it easier for us when we get
to the Q a section of the presentation
we'll be able to find them easier uh
sessions being recorded you will get a
follow-up email with a link to this
recording and information about the
bonus offer uh yeah
to request approved attendance after the
webinar
let's put your name into the server that
will appear after you leave
helpful to us to get your your
information
um
about the webinar in the survey as well
as
hearing from you
what you'd like to get as a follow-up so
I want to ask a couple of questions
about you the first one is
how much experience do you have in the
workplace
it's not
experience with blockchain but
experience in the workplace in general
I'll leave this open for about 15 more
seconds
gives us a situation of uh who's in our
audience with us today
I will close the poll in five four
three
two one
bull
and we have a
audience that's predominantly students
today
welcome people studying for the degree
and then the next
largest group of people people who have
more than five years of experience so
welcome to you as well
but we're going to be talking about uh
horses you've seen with this whole
question we'll be talking about
blockchain
the technology and the career field
uh we'll cover what the IIT concur
offers you how it gets your job ready
we'll also talk about enrollment steps
and the bonus offer that I mentioned and
we'll cover your questions
uh I'm Stuart Creek I am from Simply my
uh simpler one online boot camp in the
world uh we've been doing this for over
13 years and I've helped 5 million
professionals and counting in 150
countries uh learn new digital skill for
the digital economy
so we're very proud that IIT conquer
chose to partner with us
for this program
we deliver the program for them on their
behalf
so with us today is Dr Shukla and I will
let Dr Shukla uh
give himself a more introduction and
tell you about his background
uh okay so good evening everybody so uh
I am Professor
I am a professor of computer science and
engineering at the Indian Institute of
Technology kanpur uh in terms of my uh
area of interest and expertise I work in
cyber security and blockchain technology
and I am currently the coordinator of
the national blockchain project funded
by the National Security Council
government of India at IIT kanpur I also
coordinate the interdisciplinary Center
for cyber security and cyber defense of
critical infrastructure or c3i Center
I'm also a program director for the
Technology Innovation Hub on cyber
security or CPA hub
I did my graduate school in uh State
University at the State University of
New York uh in Albany and I worked for
Intel I worked for Verizon and then I
was a professor at Virginia Tech in in
Virginia USA for about uh 14 years and
then I moved to India and I'm now for
last almost eight years I am now with
IIT kanpur
thank you and this is the
you're at the Forefront of two of the
most new technology areas in
um in
today one is and the other is cyber
security
so we're pleased to have you with us for
this discussion so we're going to talk
about blockchain
a a career field but to set the stage I
think it's important
for people to understand
blockchain as a technology
so
can you give us the
review of what blockchain is we hear the
word a lot but
what is it actually
so blockchain is a kind of a distributed
Ledger technology so whenever we do any
kind of real world application
we have processes uh that actually need
to uh interact with data uh transform
the data from one stage to the other uh
for example when you uh are making a
payment uh through let's say a internet
uh banking uh you are basically going
through a uh your account database you
log into your account and then you fetch
data from your account database uh then
you create a transaction that
transaction does some action on the data
by debiting the amount to your uh your
account Ledger and then it actually
sends information to the receiving bank
and the receiving bank again looks at
its database and puts the the
appropriate action on that database now
if you think about this this means that
there are multiple different uh entities
your bank the receiving recipient bank
and maybe also uh in the middle uh you
know some kind of a uh other entity and
these entities are looking at data that
are in silos that are that are not
visible to each other so when your
account is visible only to your bank and
and the recipient's account is only
visible to their bank now this means
that there is a lot of possibility of
inconsistency arising there is a
possibility of friction uh which would
reduce the efficiency and also the banks
have to later on do a Reconciliation
among themselves so this makes uh this
kind of multiple multi-party processes
very inefficient and very uh problematic
so in order to reduce this friction in
order to make things transparent to all
the parties involved you can actually
think about a shared Ledger a ledger
that is shared across all parties
now when you share a ledger across all
parties then you have to also worry
about that this Ledger May uh become
inconsistent if there are malicious
parties involved then they can try to
make the Ledger State uh uh you know uh
some problematic so therefore there are
there has to be some method of
validation and some method of uh
reaching a consensus among this uh
various parties about the state of The
Ledger or state of the accounts so
that's what this uh this distributed
Ledger technology is all about now one
of the distributed Ledger technology is
blockchain in blockchain the uh the data
that is uh stored uh in a in a shared
way is actually replicated uh the same
Ledger is replicated in every party's
own machine
so so these ledgers therefore may become
inconsistent with each other and that's
why there is an expensive process called
consensus that that is required now also
so that no party can actually go back
and and revise some data from the past
there there is a process of keeping uh
the data secured by using cryptographic
techniques so in particular hashing
techniques so so each blocks a block uh
is a hash is computed for that block and
that hash is put into the next block so
this way there is a the arrows that you
are seeing in this picture basically
notional arrows these are basically
saying that the hash of blockchain is in
Block n plus one and hash of block n
plus one is in hash uh in the in Block n
plus two so as a result if you want to
change something in Block n you have to
also change the hash of block n in Block
n plus 1 which in turn will require a
change of the hash of n plus 1 in N plus
2 and and so on so therefore uh if
anybody wants to unilaterally change the
data then they have to actually make
sure that all the succeeding blocks uh
change which is a very uh time consuming
uh computationally expensive process
plus you have to have consensus on every
block across all the parties therefore
this becomes almost impossible and that
is what is called the tamper proof
Legend Ledger that is at least if not
tamper proof it's tamper resistant so
that's what blockchain is it's it's
basically a data structure which is
replicated across multiple uh parties
and uh the replicated
data structure uh even though it is
replicated it has to be always kept
consistent with each other which
requires expensive processes which makes
it very difficult for anybody to
unilaterally change past data so that is
what blockchain is all about
yeah thank you for that because that
clarifies
you know the the meaning behind the
buzzword everybody's heard of blockchain
every sort of heard of Bitcoin but
it's it's great to get that Insight it
really means and what it how it really
works so
um you know we talked about
transformation of the digital economy in
cryptocurrency and Bitcoin were the
original application for blockchain
but can you talk about how it's kind of
pervading other areas of business of
Commerce government
yeah so so the blockchain technology was
uh invented to support cryptocurrency So
Bitcoin in 2009 came about
um as first as a as a white paper and
also uh as a proof of concept uh
implementation uh which has now taken
its own uh life and uh the there is uh
also uh the uh value uh value of Bitcoin
has become very high and that itself has
given rise to many different
cryptocurrencies other than Bitcoin
which are called old coins and there is
a whole economy around it but that is
not what uh is most interesting about
blockchain because cryptocurrencies are
uh interesting they have given uh good
investment opportunity to a lot of
people but people also have lost money
by by betting on on cryptocurrency see
but the technology that was created to
support cryptocurrency has many other
transformative potentials because as I
said that blockchain is basically about
multiple parties working together on
data right so there's data and there is
a workflow that processes the data from
uh one party to another and this process
is often ridden with uh various problems
for example suppose you want to keep
track of where your
vegetables which field your vegetables
came from and why do you want to track
that is because suppose that vegetable
is supposed is found to have E coli in
it and it has to be retracted from the
market so so but not if every vegetable
of that kind has equally bacteria in it
so you do not want to throw away all the
all the vegetables of that kind let's
say spinach so what you would do is that
you would find the the original Supply
uh uh you know location and the original
Supply Farm where this uh vegetable was
sourced and how do you keep track of
this so this is done through supply
chain now in a if you think about supply
chain uh a spinach starting from the
front comes to Transportation companies
come through maybe warehouses and then
comes to main distribution station then
it gets distributed to various markets
and so on so at various points you have
to keep track of which bunch of spinach
is actually from which location so to
keep track of this you may have multiple
different computer systems which are
used by the distributor which is used by
the trans transportation company which
is used by the farm which is used by the
grocery chain and which is used by the
final grocery supplies uh grocery store
now the data then we'll be actually in
in the different silos at the different
parties will have their own data and
very quickly this thing becomes
inconsistent with each other so in such
situations it's a blockchain a shared
Ledger where everybody is writing and
reading from the same Ledger would
actually make it uh you know much more
uh much more uh you know trustworthy and
that's what blockchain gives you right
that that gives you a trustworthy source
of Truth
you know in controvertible source of
crew so similarly you know when you have
vaccines kovid vaccines it went through
from the uh Factory where it was
manufactured all the way to the final
destination where patients are actually
administered the vaccine in the middle
it has to go through various various
things transportation and so on
warehousing and so on and every place it
has to be in a certain temperature so
this is called a cold chain cold supply
chain and in order to know whether the
vaccine was ever been through a high
temperature
so that I cannot use that vaccine
anymore I need to have a trustworthy way
of verifying that this vaccine was never
outside a you know required temperature
so a blockchain based solution uh would
allow uh creating such a tracking system
much more easily than than any other
type of
siled systems so so there are also other
other kinds of systems like Payment
Systems cross-border payment systems and
so on so so blockchain has many many
different potentials it also allows you
to actually tokenize real world assets
so you can actually have a token on
residing on the blockchain whose life
cycle is managed by special programs
that only work on blockchain called
smart contracts and you can actually
have tokenization of your assets and
that way you can sell your property for
example if it is tokenized on a
blockchain by just selling the token
because token gives you a proof of
ownership so thereby you are creating a
taking an illiquid asset asset that
cannot be really more monetize quickly
to a liquid asset because you can easily
make a purchase and you can easily sell
your real estate and things like that so
you can actually have asset tokenization
on blockchain so so this is these things
are coming up this many many different
transformative applications have come up
and that gives rise to you know interest
in in blockchain technology uh across
the world and of course many of these
things are still uh in the process of
being legalized uh regulated so various
things are coming up but in general the
interest is high and uh potential is
high uh the only question is that you
know whether it is going to uh take on
take off like are people really going to
take uh you know tokenization of real
world assets uh you know seriously or or
supply chain is going to be transformed
through blockchain technology these are
certain things that are yet to be seen
but at least you know there is there is
a huge amount of interest and and there
is a growth in this sector as as you can
see in this that there is a a very large
percentage growth uh per year uh
cumulative growth and then spending is
also increasing quite rapidly uh which
gives rise to uh job opportunities and
so on
thank you yeah and and
it's
it's fascinating that uh you know one of
the aspects of blockchain is the
tie in with with security of
transactions that
we talk about uh talked about
tokenization of real estate and one of
the things that happens commonly in uh
United States now is that uh because
the ownership of property is regulated
at the local level it's possible to go
into a county recorder's office and put
a record of sale
the owner of the property actually knows
nothing about so
with
blockchain technology would be able to
prevent that from happening because you
would have
more controls over
chain of ownership and history of
transactions so
we're hoping that
things like that will take over and
it's something that everybody is
thinking these are just a few
fairly recent headlines from the news
about
blockchain as you can see it's the lower
right hand corner is what I was just
talking about blockchain uh
holding the problem of title fraud and
real estate
European country going in on uh
blockchain in the financial sector
crunch base which is a tech job in tech
industry
overview company
looking at blockchain is one of the hot
employment areas
everybody's asking about it
so
this is kind of a top of Mind topic for
people in technology and Industry yes
yeah yeah
um
people are you know some of the leaders
in business are prominent names in
business are talking about
um blockchain as a way to
prevent provide a kind of tangible
quantitative proof of things happening
rather than
um Things based on signatures and having
to trust the party the counter signs
right
yeah so uh as I was describing that if
if you have multiple different parties
and they need to have a trusted source
of Truth on which they can act on uh so
a shared Ledger is required now uh
blockchain technology actually means
that you have to replicate The Ledger on
in every party's uh machines and and you
have to also make sure that this uh
different copies are consistent with
each other and that's expensive process
so one could say that well why not have
one of the parties to keep The Ledger
and every party will connect through an
API call or some kind of way to actually
transact on that data
the problem is that who do you trust
with the data whoever you trust they can
unilaterally tamper the data right so so
there is a problem of trust that's why
we cannot keep The Ledger with a single
party per or in a centralized location
so that's why we actually keep the uh
copy of the data uh with everybody and
do mathematical
protocols and techniques and
cryptographic techniques to make sure
that these are consistent with each
other and this cannot be tampered with
by a single party or uh two parties Etc
um therefore uh you know blockchain
basically creates a uh creates trust in
a trustless and trustless environment
where the parties do not necessarily
trust each other but because the way the
blockchain technology has been created
the parties do not necessarily have to
trust each other by but they can still
cross the blockchain as a source of
truth because it has been mathematically
guaranteed to be Temple resistant and
also uh they are consistent due to their
distributed consensus algorithm so
that's what it is and because of that we
uh so basically it can replace a
centralized way of keeping a ledger to
uh keep making everybody in the network
responsible for keeping The Ledger uh as
a source of truth and that's what the
second
quote here means that it basically
shifts the power from centers to the
edges of the network right so every
Network participant is responsible for
keeping The Ledger correct Temple free
and also uh the value and uh
and the third quote here basically says
that as I was describing to you supply
chain uh you know uh you again need a
transparent way of sharing data and uh
you but you cannot trust a single party
or centralized party to keep the trusted
data so so you basically create a
blockchain Technology based way of
sharing data and working on the data so
that's what the third uh the genie
Romiti from IBM is saying
and uh so and then the last one is
basically saying that even in Securities
Market in the stock market uh if we use
blockchain technology uh it may actually
change the way the markets work and we
uh also there is uh you might have heard
about web3 and you know future uh
internet uh more decentralized internet
so that's what is uh supposed to happen
as the next evolution of the internet so
so internet has been through a lot of
transformation since it started but uh
you know uh with the blockchain
technology or the DLT the distributed
Ledger technology uh the web uh the way
we interact with the web Etc will change
uh that's the hope of the blockchain
technologists
yeah and into that
points one is to to the
IBM quote
anything that where you're looking at a
change of state can happen whereas a
transaction can happen or a physical
movement something can happen any kind
of event or change of state can happen
that's that's something that can be
represented blockchain yeah
yeah yes so that you can you can then as
you were talking about
things as diverse as the the supply
chain for scenes or the the chain of
ownership of real estate or
um
possession of cryptic all of those
things are
can be um
represented in the blockchain
um but then to the the last point you
made about web free
um this has to do also with the ability
of hitters of content to control their
own rocket ownership rather than relying
on third parties how does that work by
the way that's it yeah so so uh you see
currently the way uh Web 2.0 works is
that we
upload our content in the servers of
Facebook Google uh Etc right and
therefore we lose the uh control over
our own content the Facebook or Google
can or whoever can use the content that
we upload for monetization uh and
various other things and and they
YouTube gives you a small fraction of
what you uh actually what advertisement
Revenue they make from your content
right so now the the people are saying
that I if I create the content it has to
be uh I have to have softening control
on that that uh that content now how do
you do that you know if you don't want
to upload it into some third party or
centralized entities uh servers what you
can do is you can run your own servers
and connect it to a system by which you
actually list your content the metadata
of your content and if somebody wants to
watch your video or you know what's your
images or whatever you are you want to
share they can actually do that by
actually first transferring some tokens
to your account so then these tokens Can
you can later monetize these tokens by
selling it to an exchange or whatever
but idea is that you know one cannot
watch the content without paying
something now you can make you can also
make some of your content free so it
doesn't mean that every content will
become uh become uh you know sellable
but uh you know when you want to build
your reputation you might make your
content for free and then later on when
you become popular you can actually make
your content you know chargeable by by
some kind of uh you know blockchain
based tokens and these tokens can find
can later be monetized through an
exchange or whatever system you may have
so so that is what the dream of the Wave
3 is and uh we'll see how it pans out
it's uh rather tall order but uh there
is attempt towards that
thank you for that explanation because
that uh that clarifies you know how how
this is going to change
people's lives in ways we hadn't
expected
um so to be able to be a practitioner in
this field
um you have to have a
kind of well-rounded set of skills
around the different
aspects of
how blockchains work with the technology
behind them is and and then some of the
applications
um can you kind of discuss some of these
things that we see here some of them are
skills some of their platforms
yeah so the blockchain technology is
actually has is becoming vast and more
and more uh extensive on a daily basis
so obviously in a uh in a in a
certification course you cannot learn
everything uh what you what we plan to
do or we try to do is to actually give
you the very fundamental uh you know
basis on which you can build you can
build your expertise further so certain
things that you have to know like for
example Bitcoin is a is a is a is a
blockchain where the blockchain major
concepts are blockchain for example the
block structure the hash pointers the
idea of public key uh cryptography based
identity the idea of transactions and
and making uh you know blocks out of
transactions the idea of consensus by a
particular consensus algorithm called
proof of world over all these Concepts
together was infused into the block a
Bitcoin blockchain so first thing you
have to learn in any blockchain learning
exercise you have to learn Bitcoin even
if you do not use Bitcoin for ever again
because that gives you the very basic
understanding of the under uh
underpinning technology now to do do
this you have to learn what what are the
what is the block and how the blocks are
connected to each other through hashing
uh how the uh you know transactions are
uh you know put into a specific data
structure called martial trees uh why
the market tree not something else all
these fundamental concepts you have to
learn you also have to learn some basic
cryptography and uh and uh you know
hashing and and public cryptography Etc
to know you know how uh the how to use
the blockchain and and then since you
are learning Bitcoin you will learn
about cryptocurrency even though not
every blockchain is about cryptocurrency
so but Bitcoin is a cryptocurrency but
blockchain it was it is created to it
was created to bypass the standard
banking system and create its own uh you
know money and then make that money uh
you know uh in inflation inflation
resistant and so on so those things you
have to learn now Bitcoin actually has
this uh has this uh limitation that it
did not uh have the right kind of
programmability for example you cannot
program a complex logic of if this
happens then this transaction should
happen and if that transaction happens
in sufficient number of times then then
this third other transaction should
happen sometimes you when you build an
application on blockchain you need that
kind of complex uh you know sequence of
transactions a program that sequence of
transaction so that you do not have to
manually do them and this is done by a
notion of um you know programmability
called smart contracts so ethereum was
the blockchain that came after Bitcoin
where it basically addressed this issue
of programmability of transactions and
so ethereum is extremely important to
learn after Bitcoin to know that you
know the blockchain is not about just
putting uh transactions in blocks and
keeping them at tamper resistance and so
on I can actually build very autonomous
activities on blockchain and making sure
that this autonomous activities are
validated by everybody every party every
party makes sure that every step of the
uh of the activities on the data are
actually happening correctly and in a in
a in a valid Manner and by the right by
the right person or right entity so
that's where we learn ethereum so it's a
learning ethereum uh programming in
ethereums uh smart contract language
called solidity this is very important
so this is what you have to also learn
in any blockchain course that you would
uh imagine and obviously the methods of
consensus there are many different
methods of consensus Bitcoin has a proof
of work consensus ethereum now has a
proof of stake common senses there is
Byzantine fault tolerant consensus so
different types of consensus you will
not learn every possible consensus but
you will learn why consensus is needed
and how proof of work works and how
proof of stake works and so on
now it turns out that uh that uh Bitcoin
and ethereum has this disadvantage that
everything is visible to everybody which
leads to a problem uh when the
blockchain applications are to be used
on uh Enterprise applications where a
lot of the information is not supposed
to be a public it can be shared across
various parties involved in a
transaction but not by everybody in
Bitcoin and ethereum everybody can see
all the transactions and therefore uh
there are permission blockchains and
that's we the first uh such blockchain
that became popular was hyperledger so
hyperledger is also something you have
to learn as as an example and as
probably the most popular example of uh
of uh of a permission Ledger permission
blockchain and then you will learn you
know uh a few other blockchain and
things like which are variants of this
permission blockchain like code you will
also learn that all DLT is not just
blockchain structures there are other
structures like for example DAC
structure directed acyclic graph
structure like in Iota blockchain so you
will learn a little bit of that so that
you know that various other types of
blockchain or DLT technology exists so
this is what the and you have to
understand how the different nodes or
different parties communicate with each
other in a peer-to-peer networking
Paradigm all that stuff you have to
learn so once you learn all this then
you are self-sufficient to learn a new
blockchain let's say tomorrow somebody
says you have to develop something on
Solana blockchain even if you don't
learn it in the course you will know
exactly you know once you uh read the
documents of Solana you will know
exactly what is happening and how to
write programs in on Solana and Etc so
you will be able to do it early tomorrow
if somebody wants you to do in a in a
polygon blockchain you know you will be
able to just read the manual and and you
will be up and running so so that's what
uh this is you know so so when I say
when we say that blockchain expertise
requires a full complement of skills and
and lists these these we think is that
fundamental to the concepts and
fundamental to the uh basics of uh you
know blockchain like like if you are if
you are learning programming you cannot
learn all programming languages in one
course you will learn C or C plus plus
or Java or python or something but later
on in your in your uh day-to-day work if
you have if you say you have to program
in raster or some other language you
will pick up like like any anything so
so that's that's the idea again
thank you yeah
analogy with programming is it there's
learning the languages and then there's
learning about data structures and
algorithms which are language
independent and
give you the fundamentals so that you
can take what you know about using a
particular language and like you said
apply it to a different one so same
thing with knowing about
fundamentals of blockchain have
different platforms work gives you the
key to being able to adapt to new ones
so there's a lot of different potential
roles in this industry that people can
come into and
um
your career path can kind of follow
whatever aspect of
technology that you find fascinating
right
yes so uh so uh you know if you're if
you are good in programming and if you
like to program for developing
application then you become a blockchain
developer right so you develop
applications on top of blockchain uh uh
that that are Enterprise applications or
uh you know web free applications and so
on now uh most blockchains are
interacted with by users so users have
to interact through some kind of a
user-friendly interface so you may
actually become a interface designer so
that's the blockchain web and a user
experience designer type of activities
in that case your programming skills are
different you you will learn JavaScript
and and
that kind of HTML5 and those kind of
languages
you if you are if you are very good with
uh software architecture you you know
how to build a large scale software
with many different components and their
interaction and all that stuff then you
may become a blockchain solution
architect so your solution and architect
requires a different level of experience
with blockchain and Technology as well
as software architect architecting
software systems blockchain Engineers or
people will actually you know maintain a
blockchain make sure that the networking
Works make sure that we all the
components work with each other uh
blockchain analyst could be actually
somebody who analyzes the requirements
and and create their blockchain based
Solutions project manager will look
after a blockchain based project being
executed by by the engineers and and
developers and ux designers and solution
architect and so on there is also a
legal aspect of blockchain as I was
saying that many of these things are
still awaiting regulatory uh Frameworks
uh because a lot of it is involving uh
involving assets and and so on which is
attracting regulatory attention like
um you know Europe recently passed a a
mica which is a you know about uh the uh
virtual asset regulation so so the so
there are legal issues so there are a
lot of lawyers uh who are technologists
who were also interested in blockchain
technology and how to uh formulate the
laws and and regulations uh about the
applications developed on blockchain
great
so these two
it's not an exhaustive list here but
these are these you feel for
how you can take this set of skills and
move in different directions
um as we pointed out before the market
is growing
listering pace
so the uh
the salaries available
[Music]
when you move into uh getting some
experience in the in the industry uh can
be pretty substantial I guess
yeah so this numbers look rather low
here but uh yeah I mean this uh if you
are good in what you are doing uh of
course uh completing a certificate
doesn't mean you are good at it so you
have to also learn the subject you have
to also practice uh developing or
engineering blockchain based Solutions
imagine where you can apply blockchain
uh where it makes sense to actually
apply blockchain not every problem
requires a blockchain the solution if
you are if you are going to do that kind
of you know
understanding if you if you have that
kind of understanding so that kind of
practice and so on you can attract very
good salary because in blockchain
technology uh is the skill there is a
skill shortage in the country uh
therefore uh I think this numbers are
rather on the lower side but uh but it
makes sense
okay
um we just looked at Glassdoor India and
and saw listings of which companies are
hiring
people with blockchain skills and this
is just a sampling of them but you can
see that a lot of them are in the
consultant space such as a TCS or
Accenture PWC
and some of them are in the industrial
space or the information technology
space but really as you pointed out with
some of the other examples blockchain
for example is heavily used in
financial sector
and almost every industry
either does or will be using blockchain
I think that's one of the reasons why
I see Consultants coming in because
they're helping Industries understand
what the purpose of this technology is
and how to apply it yes so
currently most of these organizations
are actually uh either
um you know experimenting with
blockchain based solutions to actually
see whether uh uh you know they can uh
deliver uh solutioning uh with
blockchain uh where they where there is
demand and and there is fit but also uh
you know in some cases they are actually
doing uh uh based on the customer
demands uh not uh so so I think that a
lot of these hirings are are actually uh
you know right now uh uh for uh their uh
experimentation uh Consulting and
solutioning for customers but if things
take uh you know take off then there
will be a lot more uh companies uh
involved yeah
so the the future is very
um bright ahead
um this kind of it
reiterates what you were saying about
the breadth of skills and this just
points out some of the the different
platforms and tools that people use
why we need to learn these things right
yeah so a question for the audience is
you're all here because you're
interested in blockchain technology you
looked at other potential certification
programs what has stopped you from
taking that step
um is it because
you can't find a program that's as
comprehensive as what the professor
described is it because
you are concerned that you wouldn't get
practical experience in a certification
program
is it because the learning style the
teaching style or is it because of time
constraints in your work and personal
schedule so I'll leave this open just
for another couple of seconds
we'll close it in three
two one
share the result here and the primary
concern professors you can see is that
people want to make sure that they'll
get some practical experience
Hands-On examples of of the work that
they've learned to do and then
they're also concerned about
comprehensive curriculum and the
flexibility for their work schedule so
those are the concerns that people are
telling us they have in the audience
today
and
so this program is designed to address
that correctly
no so you've got a curriculum that we'll
talk about in a moment that's
comprehensive and Industry aligned IIT
com for works with many employers and
companies and organizations government
agencies so you have a good pulse finger
on the pulse of what they're looking for
in terms of skill sets and where people
can be uh yeah so so as I said before
that the uh let's say let's say uh
um you know a company is looking for
somebody who is uh working on I don't
know like polygon and uh we are are
training people with uh the very you
know fundamental concepts uh programming
programming Concepts and and ideas uh
also Hands-On on ethereum and
hyperledger and all that stuff so so the
question will be that will the person uh
will will the company that is using a
different blockchain hire somebody here
the answer is that if they they will not
uh you know uh expect that everybody
coming through their door is knowing
Solana uh what they will expect is that
they understand blockchain they
understand why it is needed where it is
needed how to create programmable
systems using blockchain using smart
contract programming and once once they
they get you know that insurance from uh
their interviews and and maybe some
Hands-On then they will uh you know
accept you so so in other words you know
uh the uh you know the specific language
or specific uh
block blockchain platform is not the
issue the issue is that whether what you
what you are supposed to know in terms
of fundamentals of blockchain and how it
is uh created and how to set up your own
let's say permission small blockchain
how to write uh smart contracts uh in
one at least one of the languages like
solidity for ethereum or or even go or
you know some other language in case of
hyperledger
if you can prove that about yourself
then you can get the job
so but that's it you know don't expect
that if you just give the minimal effort
and you will be the job ready so you
have to work really hard through the
course do all the assignments correctly
and and make sure that you do additional
studies additional reading and
additional uh you know practice create
your own portfolio of of application
design with blockchain
then you will have a very good
possibility
and that one of the aspects of how the
simple learning platform Works uh to
deliver this program
um it gives you the ability to take
online classes with instructors like
professor
and
um also to do the Hands-On case studies
and programming projects
with the virtual environment that's
provided to you so you don't have to
acquire
software or have a dedicated
system for doing your work on it's
provided to you through the online
interface
um which means that other than the
scheduled times of the live classes
you can access that learning management
system anytime so that you can
like the professor said do the
self-study pre-work for the classes or
review Concepts or re-watch a court a
class that you attended if you want to
catch up or reinforce the concepts all
that's available to you 24x7 so uh this
is an intensive program it's four months
or we talk about devoting about five to
ten hours a week of time uh so if you
can find that in your schedule you can
succeed in completing this you'll get 70
hours or so of Applied online learning
and it will culminate with the
certificate that's issued by IIT Contour
and
will have done a number of Hands-On
projects which will go into your
portfolio that includes a final project
that kind of does an end-to-end
demonstration of your ability
to apply blockchain technology and along
the way you have the option of taking
master classes from
faculty members such as yourself right
professor
right so IIT can provide the master
classes monthly monthly and those those
go into
um
additional uh you know Advanced topics
uh that may not be covered in the class
but just to give people flavor of what
uh you know newest things that are
happening in blockchain including things
like primes in cryptocurrency and and
things like that
it's great because the the
coursework keeps you kind of heads down
focused on learning the technology but
the master classes let you take a
you know kind of put your head up and
and see what's going on in the industry
and of all the institutions in the world
IIT Concourse is best situated to give
you this expertise as I mentioned it's
the hum to the India's national
blockchain project of which you are the
director Professor is that right yeah I
am the co-program director yeah
and the The Institute has been around as
long as I have which is 1959.
um so it this is a
opportunity to learn
from the people who are leading the uh
the technology Frontier in blockchain
and an opportunity to um learn from one
of the
centers of blockchain theory and
development application in the world so
having
this institution's name on your your CV
is something that people will recognize
a great learning opportunity
you want to say anything else about the
institution professor
I've been in India everybody knows about
you know iits and and IIT kanpur is one
of the earliest iits so I guess people
are familiar with the legacy of IIT Bank
uh to be in this program you do have to
have a bachelor's degree so if you are
still studying for your degree you'll
want to be uh you know in your final
year close to
um
graduation close to degree award if you
don't already have your degree because
you must have it by the time you finish
the program
um you need to have a bachelor's degree
with 50 marks or higher does not
necessarily have to be in a Technology
field but you do have to have a basic
understanding of mathematics and some
exposure to Java programming is
preferred so that you can grasp the
concepts do the the work
so it's possible to get the refreshers
in
Java programming
as you join the program but we should
come in with some of that background
um can you comment Professor on the work
experience preference why work
experience will help people succeed in
the program
yeah so uh uh What uh what we have
noticed is that uh people who are
already working or people who have work
experience has uh you know a lot more uh
you know uh enthusiasm and discipline
with respect to taking a course which is
quite a bit of self-paced right so uh if
you're just out of University
uh you actually are used to uh you know
exam oriented uh success right so you
have you pass your exam you you succeed
uh here there is no exam as such so
there is uh you know to succeed you have
to have the
um hunger in yourself to learn to uh
Excel actually not just to learn but to
excel in what you are learning and that
kind of thing uh happens uh more uh in
in people with some job experience when
they have seen the world uh seen the job
job world and you know the competition
competitiveness and importance of having
the skill and importance of having the
fundamentals sound uh but that doesn't
mean that's not we didn't make it a uh
requirement it is actually it desirable
Condition it's not a requirement but we
suggest that if you have had a
opportunity to have some experience in
Real World jobs and it really is better
yeah and to clarify that doesn't mean
work experience with blockchain because
that would be kind of self-defeating you
you want to take this program to qualify
for that work
um
so
can you um Professor describe how the
the program is structured so that
should the modules in the program takes
you you know gives the foundation for
the next module going on
yeah so so as I as I was explaining
earlier also when we were talking about
the kind of different skills that you
will have to learn so we start with the
uh Bitcoin as I said that's one of the
uh it's actually the where the
blockchain also it's all started and
then once we have a full understanding
of how they blockchain for Bitcoin works
then we will see that it does not have
the right uh you know level up
programmability that we want to create
applications on top of the blockchain so
then we go into ethereum where where it
was the first introduced the
programmability the small contracts and
so on
and then then we go into the uh issue of
uh have privacy and the the ethereum uh
Bitcoin Etc have everything out in the
open and how that actually uh you know
hampers in Enterprise uh applications
where uh data privacy may have a lot of
importance then we talk about permission
blockchain let's so we talked about hype
and and we go into hyperledger fabric
then we actually show how this how to
write smart contracts and all that stuff
uh how to create applications uh you
know with uh ethereum or with
hyperledger fabric and then we just to
give you of level of various other
distributed Ledger Technologies we give
some examples a little bit uh
introduction to order or iot Iota Etc
and then we go into applications of
blockchain by creating real applications
that that utilizes the blockchain uh
technology and then eventually the the
capture project caps it all uh by uh you
know making you do a real kind of
realistic project
which would uh you know give you a real
experience of being a blockchain
developer
and it gives you also an artifact that
you can show to people that says so this
was a challenge this is the problem that
I was uh that I chose to solve and
here's my solution
um we talked about the master classes
and they're listed here as electives but
they are included in the in the cost of
the program so they are available to you
if and when you want to take them
um and of course this professor said
they give you a great flavor of what's
going on in the industry so we always
recommend that here's a couple of
examples of the real world type projects
that uh just talked about the
professorship club about things that
might be done as part of the course
projects or the Capstone project so
um right so there will be there will be
a number of course projects where you
will actually do a smart contract based
development you'll probably uh you know
set up a hyperledger fabric Network and
and may write a small applications there
uh you understand you know you'll learn
about wallets like metamask but
eventually uh all these things will uh
be the you know components of what you
will do as a Capstone project
you will take a real world problem and
uh and try to give a solution uh with
the blockchain
something on the order of uh you know
assume you're a supplier in an industry
where you need to trace the origins and
the endpoints of the products for
quality control and how would you set up
that blockchain that type of thing
um and of course
we've all met Dr Shukla today he as I
mentioned is the coordinator of the
national blockchain project but also the
coordinator of the interdisciplinary
Center for cyber security so
occurred at the
Forefront of two major technology areas
and we're very
pleased that
you set the curriculum and you hold
simply learn accountable for delivering
it to IIT conference standards yes
right right so So eventually that the
certificate is issued by IIT concur's
continuing education centers so we have
to make sure that it has certain
standards
um to do that uh what's some of the
things that simple learn provides one of
them is a program manager who works with
Dr Shukla and IAT confer to make sure
that you know we're we're meeting those
standards
um when you join the program you on a
given date you'll be joining with a set
of other people that become your cohort
so we assign a success manager to help
Shepherd your group of Learners along
make sure that nobody gets left behind
of course the instructors in the courses
help you succeed in the individual
courses within the program and you have
the ability to draw on support from the
other members of your cohort your peers
your fellow Learners and the way the
learning management system is designed
in curriculum and materials are all
set up to help you succeed so
the learning environment lets you manage
your curriculum it will let you get an
overview of your full learning path so
you can see where you are so far and how
far you have to go it gives you specific
guidance on what you need to accomplish
to pass each of the courses within the
program gives you access to your live
virtual classroom and the virtual
environment on which you do your labs
and projects gives you access to the
tests and assessments you need
a pass in order to
um
prove your competency and move on uh it
gives you the platform you will do your
Capstone project on and allows you to
collect all the artifacts from your
different projects and labs in the
Capstone into a portfolio that you can
then take with you and show off
gives you progress tracking so that you
can see what you need to do to unlock
the next uh course certificate and
finally achieve your your program
certificate and it includes support
tools like the community feature where
you can post threads that ask questions
or you can monitor the threads posted by
your instructors for class discussion
you can also access our 24x7 help desk
you have a problem while you're working
at 3mm in the morning on a class
assignment and you want to um
address a doubt or a blocker you can in
our 24x7 help desk so
these are some Learners who have gone
through the program and
done some pretty amazing things
um Manchu is able to get a new job from
the program
uh Ashwin is uh was able to apply it and
for a client
directly so that it says start applying
the skills while he was still in the
course and
um
and Oshkosh was able to not only develop
his own digital coin but also earn a
promotion and a salary hike within his
these are people who've achieved great
things through this program we hope we
can add each and every one of you to
this roster of Learners one of the
things that simply learn provides in
addition to the instruction is job
assist services for I am with IAM jobs
in India which gives you access to their
job portal also gives you access to
their resume review and rewrite services
very important because that will help
you
re-tailor your resume so that it
highlights your new skills in a way that
the automated Bots that do the initial
evaluation of resumes uh can see those
skills match them up to job requirements
and then the resume will still be in a
format that looks good when it lands on
a human being's desk or
screen
and finally the one-on-one interview
service which allows you to practice the
different types of interviews from phone
screens to
uh
gills interviews to
teamwork and cultural fit interviews all
with a live practice partner so
these are all available to you for the
six month period following your
final certificate in the course do the
course for four months and then for an
additional six months you can draw on
these services not a job placement
service or guarantee service but a set
of tools that will help you in your job
search
So based on everything that Professor
Shukla and I have shared with you are
you interested in enrolling in this
program
launch this poll
we'll just leave it open for about 15
seconds or so it's yes or no question
and I will close the poll in three
two
one
and about three quarters of our audience
are interested
I'm reading that right yes
show you the result here about three
quarters of you said you're interested
and I will share with you how to
accomplish that
enrollment steps are very
straightforward you contact first off to
you should know the program fees which
are one lock sixty nine thousand uh
rupee
um inclusive of tax Emi financing is
available as low as
5751 rupees per month
um
to find out the bonus offer for
attending this webinar please contact
our learning consultants and ask us at
simplylearn.net and they will let you
know what that offer includes for you
that's our reward to you for attending
today's webinar
being here live with us
and enrolling in the next cohort and
so
and email us at ask us at simply
learn.net to submit your application
we'll review that verify your
educational and work qualifications
history and
send you the admission offer if you
qualify
the next cohort starts
tomorrow with the induction session but
you don't have to be
really the starter class is the 5th of
August so
um
if you are interested in getting started
you can start right away we talk about
limited seats available because we can't
put a lot of an unlimited number of
people about 25 to 30 is about the top
before it's impossible for the
instructors to give sufficient attention
to everyone
so if you are interested in getting
started please contact us right away and
if you're looking to start even later
then
this week
you can still contact us right away and
we'll keep in touch with you and ask us
at simplylearn.net
and I want to ask the question
of the people who said you were
interested
how soon do you see yourself starting is
it something you could do
this week or is it something you'd
probably do in a month or two or are you
looking for the down the road
I'll leave that open and while I do I
will
put into the chat
information with the
email address
and the program web page
go into the chat for everyone
now
and I'll close the poll
so we have a few people who are
interested in getting started either
this week or
maybe in the September October cohorts
um for those of you who are looking for
the down the road as I said please do
contact us because we will be able to
keep you informed about future cohorts
in this program and answer any other
questions you might have and speaking of
questions
this is the time in the program where we
go to questions and the answers so
Dr Shukla I've got some questions in the
Q a box here
and
so ranji who asks uh
what aspects of blockchain are the ones
that are most likely to get you a job
quickly is it in focus on ethereum or
hyperledger or anything or do you
is there really an answer to that
well I mean as I said that you know it
doesn't matter which blockchain as long
as you know how to uh use a specific
blockchain to a very good level
so if you learn how to use uh you know
solidity to learn uh to create
applications on ethereum uh I think you
will be good to go with many most other
blockchains uh if you know how to do a
hyperledger application development when
in say go uh you will be also very good
in good shape so I I wouldn't say that
yeah this blockchain is uh well most
popular in application development are
ethereum and uh and hyperledger for sure
but doesn't mean that you will get a job
opportunity in those two only
and and we did have a question from
somebody who asked about
the role of ethereum in blockchain I
think you you had covered that in terms
of how it provides programmability yes
yeah so ethereum is one of the
permissionless blockchains uh which uh
you know came right after Bitcoin and
and added the idea of programmability uh
at smart contracts and it's probably one
of the most popular one on which uh
various other blockchains depend on
various other applications depend on uh
non-fungible tokens uh erc20 tokens uh
decentralized organizations there are
Dao's uh various applications even layer
2 blockchains such as
um polygon they actually are running on
top of ethereum so so ethereum is one of
the most popular
blockchains at the moment
thank you I want to address a question
certified course available online to
confirm that yes we delivered this this
course completely online so it's
available to you wherever you are and
that you have an internet connection and
the laptop or desktop device much of the
material is also accessible to you on
your mobile or tablet so that you can do
review of material re-watch classes or
watch the self-study video materials on
those devices as well so it's very
flexible in that respect
um we talked about different
applications we had a question here how
blockchain is important in our daily
lives but I think we've talked about
that early in the webinar of everything
we're from cryptocurrency to how it can
transform
things like food safety or
identity
[Music]
yeah
so you were developing something to ask
about the real estate side you've
developed at the
uh
in India National blockchain project
applications for
blockchain and real estate for some
states in India yes
so in the state of Karnataka we
developed a solution for um the land uh
land uh transaction registry on
blockchain so that it is tamper-proof we
also recently developed for city of
kanpur a a different notion it's called
transferable development right where you
know if the government takes your land
for some uh you know government
development project they can and they
can actually give you a
blockchain based uh you know uh right
tokenized right for uh development of
another land somewhere else which uh
normally you could sell to a third party
or another developer but in this case
what happens is that because it is
digital it can be easily transferred to
another person so that's it's a
transferable development right but
earlier if it is on paper then it not as
transferable as as
the digital one is so so we developed
that
um
do you see blockchain we had a question
do you see blockchain playing a role
with the customer relationship
management things like Salesforce
um
not really I mean I don't see I one can
do it with blockchain but I don't see a
reason for doing it with blockchain
yeah you can you could see how the
customer journey and the different
interactions you have with them are form
a chain of events that could be modeled
in blockchain but the need for security
and
it's a single party that that has all
that data so exactly it makes no uh not
a whole lot of sense yeah
um on the other hand you know when you
get into delivery and that type of thing
you might have interfaces where
Salesforce accesses data from a
blockchain about that type of track
uh delivery of product to customer but
that's a separate issue um
we have a non-technical graduate who
asks if uh
how they would address the career
transition to going into blockchain
well if you are non-technical without
any
um
programming uh exposure
if you're mathematics does not include
uh you know some algebra and some things
you will have a hard time so I wouldn't
recommend it uh now if you are if you
are going to take this course to
actually say that I'm going to learn uh
the concepts of blockchain
how it works where it is used
um this kind of stuff that is your
expectation then you will get that from
this course but the all the Hands-On
stuff the programming stuff uh that that
you are going to uh that you are going
to have a hard time and
um so so if your expectation is I want
to learn uh you know how blockchain
works and where it is used then why it
is used and things like that you will
get that but a lot of the part of the
course you will be struggling
if you're a non-technical graduate but
you do have
a background in math and
programming from other activities you've
done or first of all the courses you've
taken so that you have that Foundation
that's one thing if you're uh
non-technical graduate who doesn't have
any exposure in those areas as the
professor said that makes it very
difficult for you but uh
you know there there are ways to acquire
that but you would want to do that well
before you enrolled in this program
um
how secure pardon me how secure is
blockchain technology and where are the
vulnerabilities
well the vulnerabilities are many so
blockchain technology uh as such the
data tampering is rather difficult so in
that sense data Integrity is is good
with blockchain but some you have
multiple nodes which are basically
computers or which are connecting to
each other and which are talking to each
other over Network right so you can
attack the network uh to stop some part
of the some parties to be completely
starved from information you can
actually make uh you know uh smart
contracts which have which are basically
software so they have they may have
cyber security vulnerabilities that have
we have seen being exploited many many
times over so smart contract
vulnerabilities arise uh the nodes the
where the blockchain replicas are are
are kept and worked on those nodes are
basically computed so if you do not
protect them properly with firewall and
everything you will get you might not
make it compromised so so there are many
uh vulnerabilities that can happen so
it's not so so what I'm trying to say is
that these are problems with most uh you
know Computing systems network computing
systems uh anyway uh but there is often
a misconception that using blockchain
makes everything secure and what I'm
trying to say here is that that is not
the case it has this same set of
problems as you would have in any set of
computing systems that are talking to
each other over a network and and doing
something together
the difference between transaction
security and the data security around it
um and privacy concerns are are those
addressed through
things like private blockchain platforms
uh non-public platforms
how do we address these things
no so so privacy uh concern uh seen in
permissionless blockchain uh uh you know
you do not have your identity disclosed
easily although there are ways to
actually eventually track your identity
but usually use a cryptographic uh
address for you for for your identity
which uh often masks who you are in the
real world but the transactions you do
are usually uh all uh visible to
everybody you know on the blockchain and
any anybody is allowed to connect to the
chain and get all the information about
transactions and and by analyzing the
transaction with various analysis
techniques they even May uncover who is
doing what
so that is a problem privacy problem now
in case of a permission blockchain uh
you actually do not not everybody can
join that blockchain Network and
therefore they wouldn't have access to
that data but the parties that are
involved in the blockchain they may see
all the data and and that may may also
not be acceptable in some cases so in a
in a in in many cases we do not put all
the transaction data on the blockchain
we often put the hash of the transaction
on the blockchain and therefore uh
ensuring Integrity of the data but
actual data may not be there so there
are ways to actually get privacy uh
there are also techniques such as zero
knowledge proofs so they are Advanced
cryptographic Techniques by which
privacy preservation can be done so it's
not like all uh you know blockchain
doesn't mean that you know transparency
ends to uh loss of privacy it you can
design it in a way to actually do in a
privacy preserving way
um
such that we your your actual
application is doing what it is supposed
to do
okay
um
do we expect generative AI to impact
blockchain
well generative AI has this problem that
uh it is going to generate based on what
it is trained on and there is a lot of
fake information around the world and
lot of fake identities around the world
and if you feed that data to generative
AI it will start generating fake stories
and all that stuff that's a big concern
in generative AI right now
so so there may be some application of
blockchain technology to actually uh you
know track the provenance of data so
that you can decide which data can be
can be used for training a generator API
model and uh which cannot but nobody has
done that I'm just saying that this is
something that can be thought of uh
generative AI also can write programs in
smart contract languages they are often
slightly off so you may have to manually
correct them but you can get a more
skeleton of
programs if you ask the unity VI the
right question you have to ask the right
question if you do not frame the right
question will get garbage program right
so so that is a difficult thing to ask
the right question you have to know the
technology to ask the right question but
yeah generative AI can help uh you know
do a simple smart contracts and all that
stuff if you write the right question
and it can also often help you debug Etc
so so there are there are many things
that are coming up so you might have
heard of Microsoft co-pilot so similar
things will come up in for solidity and
other languages I'm pretty sure so
narrative way I will do some uh change I
will make some changes in blockchain
across
um
you have an interesting question that
kind of I think relates to several
people's situation in terms of
uh transitioning into blockchain we have
someone who is a finance and account
manager
um you know they're making
20 luck payout right now
um
what would the
transition look like for somebody
with the look to transition into a
blockchain
engineering or analyst role or would
they
would it be possible for them to learn
blockchain skills and apply them within
their career
domain currently so that they could
remain in a senior position there
ah so that's a difficult question
because uh you know uh if their company
where they're working in Finance and
Accounting if they are not thinking
about you know transforming some
applications that they are doing in with
respect to with blockchain and stuff uh
even if he gets highly skilled in
blockchain you will not be able to get
that kind of position on the other hand
uh maybe there is another company that
is that is a little more advanced and
and also uh uh they are actually making
uh you know foreign into uh blockchain
uh based uh you know uh accounting and
stuff or or maybe cryptocurrency uh
based you know uh Futures uh ETFs and
all that stuff I don't know uh various
what kind of financial company uh you
were talking about uh maybe there is but
uh if you do not know programming and
stuff I think it will be very hard uh so
if you know programming
um have a basic idea of uh you know how
how network works and how uh you know
data structures work and so on I think
it will be pretty hard to learn a
blockchain to the extent where you can
actually transform the way business is
done in your organization
and again if you're looking to leave the
finance domain go into blockchain into
other domains
you're probably not going to expect a
straight across salary
if you're but if you're looking to add
blockchain technology knowledge into the
domain you're working with and and if
you are in an organization or know of
organizations that want that combination
of domain knowledge and
technology skills you have a much better
chance with that so
um
go ahead
without the right background will
actually
um you know translate the way you do
your uh job uh it is not right the the
right if you the attitude is that I will
learn a new technology which is
interesting to me which I think that has
uh future potential in my field and I
will wait and see when I can apply this
in my field uh opportunities will come
maybe in the future then it's a it may
be the right thing to do but if you are
expecting that you know after four
months you will be like with a similar
paying job uh in blockchain technology
that probably is not going to happen
thank you for that that's all the time
we have for questions I know that there
are more than than we could get to and I
apologize if we haven't gotten to them
but
um we would invite you to email us at
ask us at simplylearn.net
you can ask some of those questions
there and you can find out about
enrollment and I want to thank Professor
Shukla tremendously for being so
generous with your time and your
knowledge today
I know that everyone in the audience
appreciates that
thank you
and I want to thank everyone who joined
us this evening or if you're elsewhere
in the world this uh day to learn about
blockchain technology to hear about this
program and we hope that we can welcome
you all into the Learning Community with
IIT conport and simplylearn so again
thank you very much and that concludes
our webinar
thank you